How do we learn? Although Times may
change, some concepts stay the same.
Unchanging information outlast the body.
It's stored in our brain,
but can be passed down from
generation to generation.
Our brain is capable of synthesizing the
diverse set of inputs we call our five
senses and from them creating a
hierarchy of concepts. If we're lucky,
we can learn a task while being
supervised by a teacher directly.
While interacting with our environment,
we can feel our surroundings,
see our obstacles and try
to predict the next steps.
If we try at first and fail, that's okay.
Through the process of trial and error,
we can learn anything,
but what is it that gives our
brain this special capability?
Unlike anything else in nature,
everything we've ever experienced or felt,
all our thoughts and memories are very
sense of self is produced by the brain.
At the molecular level.
Our brain consists of an estimated 100
billion nerve cells called neurons.
Each neuron has three jobs,
receive a set of signals from
what are called [inaudible].
Then drives integrate those signals
together to determine whether or not the
information should be passed
on in the cell body or Soma.
And then if the some of the
signals passes a certain threshold,
send this resulting signal called the
action potential onwards via its Axon to
the next set of neurons. Oh, we're all,
it's the Raj and we're going to build
our own neural network in python.
The rules that govern the brain
give rise to intelligence.
It's the same algorithm that invented
modern language space flight Sheil above.
It's what makes us us.
It's what's allowed us to survive
and thrive on planet earth.
But as far as we've come as a species,
we still face a host of existential
threats to our existence.
There's the impending
threat of climate change,
the possibility of biochemical
warfare and an asteroid impact.
These are non trivial problems that
could take our biological neural networks
many generations to solve.
But what if we could harness this power?
What if we could create an artificial
neural network and have it run on a non
biological substrate like silicon?
We could give it more computing power
and data than any one human would be
capable of handling and haven't
felt problems a thousand
or even a million times
faster than we could alone.
In 1943 Q early computer scientist
named Warren Mcculloch and Walter pits
invented the first
computational model of a neuron.
They're model demonstrated a neuron that
received binary and puts some them and
at the some exceeded a certain
threshold value. I'll put a one, if not,
I'll put a zero. It was a simple
model, but in the early days of Ai,
this was a big deal and got computer
scientist talking about the possibilities.
A few years later,
a psychologist named Brank Rosenblatt
was frustrated that the McCulloch pits
model is still active
mechanism for learning.
So he can see it's a neural
model that built on their idea,
which he called the Perceptron,
which is another word for a single
layer feed forward neural network.
We call it feed forward because the data
just flows in one direction forward.
The perceptron incorporated the
idea of weights on the inputs,
so given some training
set of input output,
it should learn a function from it by
increasing or decreasing the weights
continuously. For each example,
depending on what its output was,
these weight values are mathematically
applied to the input such that after each
iteration,
the output prediction gets more accurate.
The best understand this
process we call training.
Let's build our own single layer neural
network in python using only num Pi as
our dependency. In our main function,
we'll first initialize our neural network,
which will later define as its own class.
Then pronounce it starting weights
for our reference. When we demo it,
we can now define our dataset.
We've got four examples.
Each example has three input
values and one output value.
They're all ones and Zeros.
The t function transposes the
matrix from horizontal to vertical,
so the computer is storing
the numbers like this.
We'll train our neural network on these
values so that given a new list of ones
and Zeros,
it be able to predict whether or not
the output should be a one or zero.
Since we are identifying
which category it belongs to,
this is considered a classification
task and machine learning.
We'll train our network on this data
by using them as arguments to our train
function as well as a number 10,000
which is the amount of times we'd like to
iterate during training.
After it's done training,
we'll print out the updated weights so
we can compare them and finally it will
predict the output. Given a new input,
we've got our main function ready,
so let's now define our neural network
class. When we initialize the class,
the first thing we will
want to do is seed.
It will initialize our weight values
randomly in a second and seeding them.
Make sure that it generates the same
numbers every time the program runs.
This is useful for debugging.
Later on we'll assign random weights to
a three by one matrix with values in the
range of negative one to
one with a mean of zero.
Since our single neuron has three input
connections and one output connection.
Next we'll write out
our activation function,
which in our case will be a sigmoid.
It describes an s shaped curve.
We passed the weighted sum of the inputs
through it and it will convert them to
a probability between zero and one.
This probability will
help make our prediction.
We'll use our sigmoid function
directly in our predicts function,
which takes inputs as parameters and
passes them through our neuron to get the
weight that some of our inputs will
compute the dot product of our inputs and
our weights.
This is how our weights govern the
attention of how data flows and our neural
net and dysfunction will
return our prediction.
Now we can write out our trained function,
which is the real meat of our code.
Well, write a four loop to iterate
10,000 times as we specified.
Then use our predict function to pass
the training set through the network and
get the output value, which
is our prediction. Well,
next, calculate the error,
which is a difference between the
desired output and our predicted output.
We want to minimize this error as we
train and do this by iteratively updating
our weights.
We'll calculate the necessary adjustment
by computing the dot product of our
inputs transpose and the error multiplied
by the gradient of the sigmoid curve,
so less confident weights are adjusted
more and inputs that are zero don't cause
changes to the weights.
This process is called gradient descent.
I'm the sending that gradient.
Oh,
we'll also write out that function that
calculates the derivative of our sigmoid,
which gives us its gradient or slope.
This measures how competent we are of
the existing weight value and helps us
update our prediction in the
right direction. Finally,
once we have our adjustment,
we'll update our weights with that value.
This process of propagating our error
value back into our network to adjust our
weights is called backpropagation.
Let's demo this baby in terminal.
Because of the training set is so small,
it took milliseconds to train it.
We can see that our weight values updated
themselves after all those iterations
and when we fed it a novel input,
it predicted that the output
was very likely a one.
We just made our first neural network from
scratch anyways about backpropagation.
I
date update weights,
backed up update wave that
propagates the update rate backdrop,
update weight [inaudible] and
knows map to owes him ones inputs.
Go in, add weights, get someone's past
that shit too. Must sigmoid function.
Get that error, woods real and prediction.
And that's why I use gradient descent.
It gives direction and it doesn't pretend
update weights and repeat 10,000 times
outputs are lit.
I'll be doing just fine.
So as dope as Rosenblatt's idea
was in the decades following it,
neural networks didn't really give
us any kind of note the results.
They could only accomplish simple things.
But as the worldwide web grew from a
certain project to the massive nervous
system for humanity that it is today,
we've seen an explosion in data and
computing power and a small group of
researchers funded by the
Canadian government held
fast to their belief in the
power of neural networks to help
us find solutions from this data.
When they took a neural net and made
it not one or two but many layers deep,
gave it a huge dataset and
lots of computing power.
They discovered that it could outperform
humans in tasks that we thought only we
could do.
This is profound.
Our biological no network is carbon
based sending electro chemicals like
Acetylcholine and glutamate and
Serotonin as signals on artificial neural
network doesn't even
exist in physical space.
It's an abstract concept
we programmatically created
and it's represented on
silicon transistors. Yet despite
the complete difference in mediums,
they both develop a very similar mechanism
for processing information and the
results show that perhaps there's a
law of intelligence encoded into our
universe and we're coming ever closer
to finding it. So to break it down,
a neural network is a biologically
inspired algorithm that learns to identify
patterns in data.
Backpropagation is a popular
technique to train a neural network,
but continually updating weights.
The gradient descent,
and when we train a many layered deep
neural network on lots of data using lots
of computing power,
we call this process deep learning.
The coding challenge winner
for last week is Ludo Blonde.
Little made a really slick
I python notebook to demo,
not just today regression,
but 3d regression as well on a climate
change dataset wizard of the week and the
runner up is Amanullah Tariq.
He completed the bonus with great results.
The challenge for this video is
to create a, not one, not two,
but three layer feed forward neural
network using just num Pi. Post your gate,
humbling in the comments,
and I'll announce the winner in one week.
Please subscribe and for now
I've got to update my weights.
So thanks for watching.